you've returned to mandela county
foolish
nobody will find you
nobody knows you are here
nobody knows
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
where we understand or at least we try
to and today what we're trying to
understand are the supernatural
mysteries happening over in mandela
county where children are going missing
humans are being replaced with
doppelgangers and a mysterious face
keeps appearing on late night tv
oh it's so awful
much better now if you haven't seen our
previous theory on the mandela catalog
an analog horror series here on youtube
then i highly recommend that you start
over there because this series is dense
link is down in the description or
provided youtube isn't stroking out it
should be over in that recommended feed
next to the video the overall gist is
that the fictional mandela county has
been the epicenter of a rash of horrific
and seemingly paranormal crimes over the
past few decades first and foremost over
3 400 children have gone missing
seemingly unrelated to that a strange
species of creature known as alternates
have invaded with the ability to mimic
humans these things come in three
different flavors type 1 alternates look
like normal people and seem to have the
ability to blend into regular society
type 2 alternates have unrealistic
proportions like long arms and stretched
out faces making them a lot more obvious
to see but also a lot more frightening
and type 3 alternates are described as
having biologically impossible
characteristics depicted by an upside
down figure to my knowledge we haven't
seen any of these yet at most they've
been censored but honestly i don't think
i want to know what they actually look
like regardless of the type we've seen
that alternates can be incredibly
dangerous they phase into reality tell
you something and that little chat tends
to infect the victim with mad short for
metaphysical awareness disorder at which
point you have like a 97 chance of
self-destruction it's not like they
suddenly turn you into an electrode i
mean death by your own hand if you catch
my bran friendly drift and if all of
that wasn't enough there's also a creepy
face called the intruder who enters
houses late at night through any tv
screens people might have hanging around
so really mandela county just worst
place to live and that's largely where
we left off last time but at the top of
this year the mandela catalog volume 2
dropped a 20 minute upload that gives us
a ton of world building and a whole lot
more to speculate about finding places
for some puzzle pieces while putting
more on the table this time we're taken
all the way back to the ancient and
spooky year of 2009.
oh i'm starting to have flashbacks to
that time that i watched gi joe rise of
the cobra
but x-men origins wolverine was the
worst movie of 2009. no yeah kanye was
shamelessly interrupting people a
terrifying year indeed volume 2 follows
adam murray and jonah marshall two
members of the bi-thorn paranormal
society it's worth noting that bythorn
was actually called out as one of the
counties affected by child
disappearances mentioned back in season
one and that being associated with this
society is why these two are apparently
wanted criminals the two are contacted
by a woman hoping the duo can
investigate her house for spiritual
evidence of a dead cat which supposedly
keeps her up with its haunting meowing
at night she specifically mentions that
she doesn't think it's an alternate
really a freaking cat alternate shh
i don't think it's an alternate they
accept the job and on their way over we
get some interesting world building the
fact that here in 2009 the existence of
alternates is well known but also hotly
debated
there aren't even alternates it's also
clear that at this point in history
everyone knows about the existence of
the intruder and have taken steps to try
and prevent his invasion with stuff like
tv screens removed from all households
they didn't have to outline these things
did they like i doubt that guy's face
could appear on something like this and
you know kill you when they arrive at
the house unsurprisingly some weird
things start to happen curtains get
moved cameras go down radio start
malfunctioning oh my god behind you dude
seriously
adam is approached by an alternate and
gets this truth bomb dropped on him
yo type 2 alternate be spitting some mad
facts here okay in all seriousness you
didn't miss anything that was all
gibberish but it doesn't mean that that
interaction wasn't important what we
just witnessed is them trying to infect
adam with mad i'm guessing that what was
whispered here was some metaphysical
truth about humanity's place in the
universe something that tends to make
people lose their minds and end their
lives however adam is okay he's still
alive why well as we learn about matt in
an earlier upload people only lose it
when they don't want to know the
information m80 is a result of exposure
to verbal information that is not
desired to be known the subtitles even
seem to allude to this in the immediate
aftermath of adam's encounter saying
quote it's not difficult to avoid the
patient must try to actively seek it out
this is also probably why adam's been
immune to the encounters he's had with
alternates up to this point in his life
he wants the information he's not scared
by it these things have taken so much
away from us you still run to them every
chance you get you're not invincible
okay i know you thought that when we
started doing these death marches and
nothing happened and i get it but this
right here is real eventually adam makes
his way down to the basement on the wall
are the words nothing is worth the risk
this message is the same one that we saw
given to emergency responders when they
were told not to reveal their fears over
the phone back in season one nothing is
worth the risk nothing is worth the risk
nothing is worth the risk again we get
this repeated theme of fear being the
thing that puts you at risk but adam by
showing that he's not afraid seems to be
able to survive these encounters he also
finds a 4x3 television set notable
because in our timeline those things
were long out of style in 2009 this
indicates that the tv has been kept here
for a long time since the anti-intruder
screen purge remember in this universe
tvs are no longer a thing that are
supposed to exist on the tv is an image
of a cat the cat's meowing is replaced
briefly by a music box style recording
of somewhere over the rainbow before the
now familiar image of the intruder
appears front and center when adam asks
the intruder what he is the screen
flashes to a series of images from
season one including the department of
temporal phenomena splash screen as well
as images of mark heathcliff a victim of
the alternates back in 1992 when an
otherworldly voice asks what have you
done adam responds i take the right
thing nobody is
[Music]
again he's confident and unafraid of his
actions you'll notice that adam's answer
is immediately followed by a female
voice one that if i were to guess is
adam's lost female friend sister
whatever it was he was looking for as
hinted at earlier in the video i wish we
never looked for you
because she is dead and gone and we were
never gonna get her back meanwhile
adam's friend jonah drives away in
terror all while his gps chides him in
the voice used by the false angel from
the season 1 upload overthrown
which makes it a good time to talk about
the character names this series is very
clearly connected to biblical stories
there have been hidden bible verses in
the closed captions there's been talk of
angels and false shepherds even the
first image of the series is a corrupted
clip from a video series called the
beginner's bible and here we're watching
the fallout of two biblically named
characters jonah and adam jonah as most
people vaguely know is the guy that got
swallowed by a fish in the bible what
people might not know about that story
is the reason he became fish food you
see god sent jonah to go tell the city
that they were about to get wrecked
unless they changed their sinful ways
jonah chickens out and runs away
ultimately leaving the city to die while
on a boat trying to escape from the
presence of the lord the sea gets real
rough and won't calm down until jonah is
yeted off the side and into the water
gulp fish food now what do we have here
in the mandela catalog jonah refusing to
stick with adam running away from the
scene and leaving his friend to die and
of course there's adam first man the one
created by god in his likeness and who
eats the apple of enlightenment only to
himself get yeaded out of the garden of
eden in fact we explicitly see that
exact scene from the bible in this
upload of the mandela catalog that's
probably not even looking oh go ahead
suddenly i feel kind of scared even
though adam ends this upload talking to
the intruder something tells me that we
haven't seen the last of him but we
couldn't understand what gibberish the
alternate was saying to him earlier we
do have this other conversation which
begins to reveal a lot about the world
[Music]
this conversation seems extremely
important for several reasons first it
immediately shows us that this is a
world that has two rival factions going
head-to-head against each other the
shepherd and whoever is speaking to us
here my guess is that it's the intruder
the guy ultimately on the tv screens so
it's a battle between the false shepherd
and his army of alternates i'm guessing
that's who we see in the first upload of
the series versus the intruder who's
kidnapping kids through their tv screens
you are either following one or the
other great really good options there
friends so which is right well in order
to understand that we have to talk a bit
more about adam and the intruder you see
i think the intruder might not be
working against us in the long term
while the intruder does seem to be
making children disappear i suspect that
he might be doing this to save the
future of humanity future being the key
word here i want to focus on a detail
that i've largely ignored thus far the
department of temporal phenomena we
first see their logo at the very start
of volume one so you know this one's
gotta be important but with a name like
temporal phenomena it seems to imply
that there's some kind of time travel at
play so why would a time travel
department be handling the disappearance
of children and the appearance of
doppelganger alternates well i believe
the intruder knows who's gonna become
alternates in the future and he's trying
to stop them before they become part of
the unholy army that ends the world
consider this we know that this is a
story full of biblical illusions and in
the canon of catholic church anyone who
ends their own life winds up in satan's
army considering taking a life as a sin
and if you take your own life there's no
time for you to repent and be forgiven
this then leads me to believe that the
alternates are working directly for the
false shepherd satan notice that
alternates don't kill you they trick you
into doing it yourself by giving you
unwanted information and turning you mad
but by heading them off at the past the
intruder is able to thin their numbers
in the video volume 1 we follow the
journey of mark heathcliff a young man
who after trying to help his friend is
followed home by an alternate that keeps
him trapped in his room after a few days
of being a prisoner mark ultimately
winds up dead by his own hand the false
shepherd wins however the video also
rewinds back to earlier in mark's life
where we learn that he's been visited by
the intruder since his childhood the
intruder also flashes images of mark and
his sister in front of the church when
adam asks who he is which indicates that
the intruder knew mark and his sister
when they were kids let's look back to
what's said about adam in this video
wake up it's almost like the intruder is
taking kids and planting ideas in their
heads so they're protected and unafraid
of the alternates then when the time
comes like sleeper agents they're
activated that's why adam's been so
inexplicably obsessed with alternates
it's why he's been able to stay safe
from their attacks it's also if i were
to guess what happened to his sister
friend whatever the girl that he's
looking for and that's why he's being
told to wake up now the intruder is
asking do you understand in other words
do you understand that you're now being
called into service and what's more if
adam can't do the job there are others
waiting to be awoken now don't get me
wrong i'm not trying to say that the
intruder is the good guy he still seems
to be taking children away from their
parents but regardless i do think that
the intruder is specifically working
against the alternates trying to starve
them by culling their food source by
doing something unspeakably evil he's
doing his best to prevent a global
catastrophe that happens in the future
so there you have it the uplifting tale
of the mandela catalog a story of
religion time travel and old sony
cameras like i said i get the sense that
we haven't seen the last of adam in this
story but we can all take away this
lesson the next time a creepy edvard
munch looking character decides to be a
real close talker to you and starts
whispering into your ear just be excited
to learn that humanity is a mere pimple
in the face of existence otherwise
things might not end too well for you
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cut
you